الاستهداف الذي تم
للسياره في خربه سلم حيث يشيع وسام الطويل
هل هناك معلومات اكثر بشان الاصابات التي
نتجت عن هذا
الاستهداف نعم هنالك معلومات اوليه مؤكده
عن وقوع اربع اصابات ولكن هنالك معلومات
اضافيه وصلتني ولكن تحتاج الى مزيد من
التدقيق وهي تتحدث عن شهيد ثلاثه جرحى
وبالتالي الان ما يمكنني ان اجزم به بان
ثمه اربع اصابات في هذا الاستهداف ولكن هل
استشهد احدهم احد هؤلاء المصابين بجروح
بالغه هذا الامر سنحتاج الى مزيد من الوقت
للتاكد منه ولكن من الواضح بان هذا
الاستهداف بهذه الطريقه استهداف السياره
يعني بان
عمليا الصواريخ التي اطلقتها الطائرات
الاسرائيليه او تحديدا الطائره المسيره
الاسرائيليه
لي
منبح سما لان ما شهدناه سابقا على سبيل
المثال في ع الشعب اطلقت الصواريخ على
سبيل التحذير اما اليوم فان يتم الاستهداف
لاحدى السيارات في تلك البلده التي تقترب
من محاوله الى وسط البلده للمشاركه في
جنازه تشييع القائد الميداني العسكري في
حزب الله وسام الطويل فهذا يعني ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اتخذت قرارا بارسال
رساله دمويه الى المشاركين هنا في في هذا
في هذه المراسم التي نراها ونرى الحشود
الان التي تتجمع هنا في وسط بلده خربه سلم
وبالمناسبه خربه سلم لا تعتبر من من قرى
الحافه الاماميه بمعنى انها من الحافه
الخلفيه او فلنقل هي من الخطوط الخلفيه
للمواجهه مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذه
البلده التي تبعد في بعض في بعض قطاعاتها
الجغرافيه اكثر من 12 كيلومترا عن الحدود
الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان يمكن ان نعتبر بان
الاستهداف هنا بالاضافه الى الاستهدافات
المتعدده في اكثر من مكان تحمل رسائل عن
كسر كل القواعد التي كنا نرصدها خلال
المرحله الماضيه والتي كانت على اساسها
تدور المواجهات وبالتالي الليله مجددا
الاستهداف بات يحصل مرتين هنا في خربه سلم
الاستهداف الاول كان من خلال اغتيال هذا
القيادي العسكري في في حزب الله واعقب ذلك
اليوم توجيه هذه الصواريخ احدى السيارات
التي كانت تعبر طريقا على مقربه من منزل
شقيق وسام الطويل القيادي في حزب الله